well joining me now is Ryan colasso
who's been stopped and searched
repeatedly by police since he was 16.
now good morning to you Ryan um how many
times has this happened to you
um so it did start generally when I was
16 in about 30 odd times it gets to a
point where you start to lose count
because it becomes quite a repetitive um
pattern in your life
um but yeah it started as young as 16
and
um well some things initially were maybe
not as traumatized as the Sean's were
you know a lot of the vague reasons
um concerning
um things said along the lines of oh you
you've um aroused our suspicion oh
you've put your hands in your pockets um
obviously they never found anything but
this is very traumatizing for a very
very very young mindset because it's
just it becomes uh something that you
have to accept is going to consistently
happen in your life and when you're at
such a young vulnerable age
um you know your mental health does
suffer yes I mean I didn't expect you to
say 30 odd times it must just almost be
like part of life uh for you and I I was
reading in one article that once you
were sitting in your car and your car
window was smashed by police is that
right
yeah um so for me that was the worst
situation that's happened to me
definitely not the worst situation I've
actually had in my inbox and you may
have heard me say 30 odd times but I've
had people tell me and in inbox me
saying um had been stopped in search as
much as 150 times in their life you know
which is as much as five it's five times
more than me so yeah I've had my windows
smashed in my police it's continued into
adulthood I work as a location manager
in the film industry so I do have to
drive to get around so whilst it
happened to me on foot even when I was
younger even when I'm driving now it's
happening had my window smashed in I've
had police officers like routinely and
you know there is a very very strong
um strong distrust in the police you're
not as um this whole system for me is
institutionally racist and I I just
don't believe that we're we're gonna
actually get anywhere until this is
properly admitted and properly acted
upon and Ryan in any of those 30 odd uh
instances including uh not least the one
where your car window is smashed have
you ever had an apology
well I've had a forced apology um not
too long ago but again why do I need to
have to drag an apology out of a police
force you know at least 30 odd times
there's one time actually where my car's
been trashed and I just walk away
shrugging their shoulders they'll even
leave your stuff under um on a brick
wall and a side of a pavement after the
session your pockets and just walk away
um I've never as far as I'm concerned
that apology as much as it was um forced
to me it's not it's not an apology so
yeah I've had one if you want to say on
paper yes but you know because they know
there's no accountability for their
actions that they they can do whatever
they want and they'll continue working
unlike um ordinary members of the public
who would be subject to much um harsh
consequences
now the spotlight is on the Met police
isn't it uh lots of things have been
coming out uh from there including um
them being termed institutionally racist
are you hopeful of any changes coming
through
well
um if we cast our minds back to 2020
quest of the dick actually said you know
that institutional racing didn't exist
she was um very very sternless where she
um said that and you know I know Mark
Rowley is saying that now he's the new
commissioner but he's forced to say that
because we've been getting the publicity
for it you know black and ethnic
minority police officers themselves
within the forces have said for years
for decades they've experienced
institutional racism so I I don't I'm
not hopeful at any change I just think
they're acting because we are um we are
pushing we're knocking on the door and
we're saying look this needs to change
you know we're in the age of social
media we're in an age where we could
actually get our points of view across
you know and also body cam footage when
they send that over they do blur it out
um and they do you know put it in favor
of the police so I think yes they're
saying that they have to act but this is
just because they want to silence us for
now at least when
um whilst they go about their normal
duties you know I don't have any trust
if I get stuck jobs and such now again I
I feel that my window might be smashing
again I feel like they might steal stuff
again
um you know there's quite a lot of um uh
distrust in the police from young people
and it carries on to adulthood and now
I've got evidence against the police as
well so no I'm I just think they're
talking for cameras at the minute
and can I just ask um how does it feel
when you're stopped and searched when
you're with your friends when you're
just out walking on the street
um it's quite horrific
um and you know it's for it to happen in
adulthood it's even worse I've actually
had it happen to me at my workplace
obviously I work in film so um a lot of
the time I am in different locations so
I've had police officers
um you know stop me whilst I'm on set
you know I'm taking pictures for the
director at the minute and now I'm
getting stopped in search you know this
is very humiliating I work at people
from different backgrounds so I'm not
used to this so when some people see
this they might think oh they must be
suspicious because they're not they're
not um aware of um you know the
corruption in the police and the whole
um system so no it's extremely
humiliating it's very it's very
terrifying as well
um you know whilst I've been able to
deal with things because I've just had
to you know a lot of people can't I've
got people pleading me for pleading with
me for help because of the things that
are happening when they're getting
stopped and searching where it could
affect your career when police are
saying all these they're throwing
accusations your way and saying that
you're you know a drug dealer hiding
drugs in your waist When They smash your
window you know these things can ruin
your career but we're seeing these
police officers that are doing these
things still in their jobs there's no
accountability there's zero
accountability so they're going to
continue to do this because they do not
face any consequences whilst if we you
know even for a fraction of what they've
done
um if we did anything a fraction of what
they've done you know we we'd be sitting
in the cell
Brian Colosso good to talk to you this
morning thank you for your time on Sky
News thank you